really glad you're able to join us
because we want to show you something
that's pretty extraordinary actually
we're internepro it's a large industrial
city
in eastern ukraine and we're going to
give you a glimpse of the ukrainian war
effort but not in the way perhaps you
were thinking originally
so
are hundreds and hundreds of people here
in dinipro who have come to the center
of town
and they are in the process here in this
section
of making molotov cocktails you see them
they're taking styrofoam they've sort of
grated the styrofoam
and they're now putting it into the
bottles the styrofoam
works to make the molotov cocktail
sticky to help it stick
to vehicles
to other targets as well you can see
them grating it
and they're making it according to a
recipe that has been distributed
by the ukrainian ministry of defense
really quite extraordinary see there's
so many people here
doing this
all men between the ages of 18 and 60
have been mobilized
they're not allowed to leave the country
many people
are expected to fight and i think what
this shows is that many people in this
country are willing to fight
it's not just
not just people signing up to fight
though
just uh in the background you can see
people bringing in supplies
food water blankets sleeping bags
anything they think that will help the
army
also idps as well bringing in supplies
for idps and this really is the whole
community in action supporting
each other
a lot of people here feel like
they have to do something they want to
do something
and i think it's
one of the interesting things is that
many of the people in this community are
russian speakers they are ethnic
russians
but there is very very little support
for the russian invasion for vladimir
putin in fact we have to be careful
because
we don't want
people to to swear
there are various chants that people
will use about vladimir putin
there's very very deep feeling here
people are really angry about what is
happening
i think
one of the things that is absolutely
fascinating is that they're willing to
do this the people are so united they
are facing
they are facing one of the world's
mightiest
militaries
one of the world's
strongest most mighty military forces
and they have made inroads into this
country they are advancing
and people here are willing to fight